إنها رياضة تمتد عبر الأجيال
صغارًا وكبارًا على حدٍ سواء ، حيث يشاركك
حب اللون الأخضر
وممارسة الرياضة مرة واحدة على الأقل شهريًا قد
يضيف سنوات إلى حياتك التي
قام الباحثون بتحليل البيانات من
دراسة صحة القلب والأوعية الدموية
التي قاسوا عوامل الخطر لأمراض القلب
والسكتة الدماغية في هؤلاء.
خضع المشاركون البالغ عددهم 65 عامًا أو أكبر
لامتحانات وزيارات منتظمة كل ستة أشهر
خلال فترة 10 سنوات بمجرد
انتهاء تلك الاختبارات ، تم الاتصال بالمشاركين
لتحديد ما إذا كانوا قد أصيبوا بنوبة
قلبية أو سكتة دماغية.
بعد
شهر من
المقارنة بين لاعبي الغولف وغير لاعبي الجولف ،
وجد الباحثون أن لاعبي الجولف لديهم
معدل وفيات أقل بنسبة 8 في المائة من جميع
الأسباب
مقارنة بغير لاعبي الجولف ،
يقول المؤلف الرئيسي للدراسة إن
التعرض المنتظم لممارسة الرياضة
لبيئة أقل تلوثًا
والتفاعلات الاجتماعية التي توفرها لعبة الجولف
كلها إيجابية بالنسبة لـ  الصحة للدقيقة الصحية اليوم
أنا ماندي جيثر